well it only took a month but finally
while i was away on vacation the
mainstream media deign to acknowledge
the existence of my film what is a woman
which is still available to watch by the
way what is woman.com in an article in a
in the prestige scumrag new york
magazine titled the rights dangerous
just asking questions anti-trans
campaign is working writer malcolm
harris
offers something of a i guess a review
of the documentary although as we'll see
he spends most of the time reviewing a
version of the film that i didn't make
but which he wishes i had made
so it begins with this claim he writes
quote
over time words change stretched by the
practicalities of real world usage or
our language evolves and warps it's an
organic unavoidable and even auspicious
process now
we can already see the difficulty here
harris conflates
warp
and evolve
as though the two are synonyms
but they're not
and what could be more revealing than
somebody on the left thinking that warp
and evolve
are the same idea they're not at all
um what has happened to the word woman
in modern times and and so many other
words besides that one
is an example of language being warped
but it's not an example of language
evolving okay language evolves gradually
organically in order to make meaning
more clear in common usage but what's
happened with the word woman has not
been gradual it has not been organic and
it certainly has not made the meaning of
the word more clear
this is a top-down decree from people
with institutional power simply
declaring all at once that the word no
longer means what humans for millennia
thought it meant
not only that but
anyone who insists on the old meaning
is subject to various penalties
okay that's that's not language
evolution
that's always a good hint by the way
when there's when when language has
changed
and um
there's there are penalties put in place
for people who don't keep up with the
change that's a pretty good indication
that it's not actually evolution of
language
because evolut evolution of language
natural evolution of language doesn't
have its own law enforcement arm that
goes with it okay
this this is what it looks like when
language is forcibly warped
it's not what
it looks like when language evolves
harris can't tell the difference between
the two and that's his first problem
though it's certainly not his only one
now he continues the new anti-trans
documentary what is a woman begs its
title question not in the sense of
suggesting it but in the fallacious way
of assuming its own answer despite
mountains of evidence the movie's
producers and on-screen guide right-wing
pundit matt walsh do not believe that
people can change their gender actually
as walsh reveals by the end he doesn't
accept that humans express gender at all
he hand waves at chromosomes once or
twice but he leans hardest on common
sense there are boys and girls men and
women males and females penises and
vaginas
mountains of evidence he says
now it should already go without saying
that harris never provides any of this
evidence
there's a whole mountain of it out there
supposedly and yet he doesn't extract
even one pebble from this mountain and
present it to us
there's no link there's no citation
there are no examples the mountain is
invisible it would seem but it's there
okay and it's really really big you guys
but we just have to take his word for it
is all
next hilariously you know he heard you
heard me there you heard him there he he
chides me for
leaning hard on common sense
as if that's a bad thing
we already know that using common sense
is the ultimate sin the great heresy on
the left you're not supposed to rely on
common sense
that is you're not supposed to rely on
the fundamental understanding of reality
shared by nearly everyone who's ever
lived that's what common sense is
instead you're supposed to rely on the
uncommon and insensible sense of guys
like malcolm harris
and yet
merely a sentence after accusing me of
using common sense accusing me of it
harris switches gears and declares that
the film and all of my ideas about
gender are rooted in religious precepts
he writes quote by disguising a
religious precept as a reasonable
question walsh and his team have set out
to win new friends and encourage
existing allies at the same time it's an
effective strategy the majority of us
who understand the factual existence of
trans people can't afford to ignore them
matt walsh is a christian and he
believes that his god is the source of
our shared single nature he also
believes that his god is my god and your
god and everyone's god
quote god exists god is existence god is
reality god is permanent inexhaustible
unending god is identity the origin of
our own identity is found in god he
writes in 2017's the unholy trinity
blocking the less assault on life
marriage and gender transgenderism as he
calls it always in scare quotes
it means that man achieves his final
victory over truth and truth's god
okay it's clear from what he might
charitable well we might shareably call
his writings that walsh is a christian
fundamentalist who is personally and
professionally dedicated to making sure
god's law is law and yet in his biggest
most prominent piece of content yet
walsh never talks about his god at all a
curious omission in a movie about
reality and identity
now he goes on from here continuing to
quote a book i wrote five years ago
calling me a religious fundamentalist
he mocks ideas like transubstantiation
he calls fans of my movie my
co-religionists
now i hate to say i told you so uh to
those conservatives who criticized my
film for not having an explicitly
biblical message
but uh i told you so
it is strikingly clear from this new
york times mag this new york magazine
article that the opponents of the film
really wish that i had framed it in
religious terms
they want our arguments on this topic to
be entirely faith-based and biblical
they desperately need us to be seen as
making a religious case
because
they are making a religious case
they want the the war over biology to be
a holy war our religion against theirs
then we can't criticize them for being
doctrinal and dogmatic because we're
being the same way we would all be in
the same boat or maybe if not in the
same boat we would be in different boats
floating on the same sea
but there's no reason for us to play the
game on those terms
i am a devoutly religious person i of
course stand by everything i said in the
in my book that he quoted there all of
that is 100 true and i'm proud that i
wrote it and i'm glad that he quoted it
but um that has absolutely nothing at
all to do
with my conviction that women have
babies and men don't
okay i didn't learn that from my
religion and even if i didn't believe in
my religion i would still recognize this
truth just as i would know that two plus
two equals four no matter if i was a
christian or a hindu or a buddhist or an
atheist
they are the religionists on this issue
the writer of this article so badly
needs to argue the matter on religious
terms that he's simply inventing a
religious angle that doesn't exist in
the film and arguing against that
instead so he's basically saying
well you didn't make it uh this your
argument religious but i know that it's
really religious so i'm going to argue
against it as if it is
later he writes quote
what is a woman throws trans women's
existence into question
the form of inquiry can be divorced from
its content and to ask if trans women
are really women is not just asking
questions especially if a bigot deity
has already told you the answer and
especially if you're spending a pile of
cash on advertising
so there he is again bringing god into a
review of a film that as he admits or
rather laments never mentions god at all
he also says that the movie throws trans
women's existence into question
though of course
i don't at all question the existence of
people who identify themselves as trans
women
those individual human beings do
certainly exist
if they didn't there'd be no need for
the movie
what i question are the claims those
people make about themselves so the
people exist absolutely
um but they they make claims about the
world and about themselves
and some of those claims are incorrect
that is my contention
just as i don't deny the existence of
anorexics though i do deny the reality
and factual validity of their
self-perception specifically the
perception of themselves as obese i deny
that
more from the article says if you press
play on what is a woman which i advise
not doing with the accurate factual
knowledge that some women are trans i
have a hard time imagining anything
walsh has to offer will confuse you
anyone with some background on the topic
knows that the anti-trans interviewees
which include a hateful doctor a
regretful phalloplasty recipient and a
sore loser cis student athlete are not
representative figures
so we have another gear shift here as he
goes from
admitting that the film is devastatingly
effective i mean he says so right in the
headline to shrugging it off as sort of
weak and irrelevant he also demonstrates
how the transgender
gives men license to say things about
women that they would never get away
with saying otherwise
so here he just scornfully writes off a
young woman who simply wants a fair
playing field calling her a sore loser
that
men
can only talk about women and two women
in that way in the context of the trans
debate that's the only time that's ever
allowed
then um
after accusing me of deliberately
inciting violence he wraps things up
this way he says quote
if that's the anti-trans playbook then
walsh is a player coach leading by
example with what is a woman they've
spent millions to take the strategy to a
new level the plan is working this
year's pride month looks to have a
casualty count if walsh and his ilk are
successful next years will be higher
they're begging for it
now bucking the trend throughout most of
the article he does attempt to provide
some evidence for the pride month
casualty count claim so he links to an
article in the baltimore sun from a few
weeks ago
about a row home fire in the city which
occurred across the street
from where somebody allegedly burned a
pride flag
and a few people were injured in the
house fire
now there's no known connection between
the alleged flag burning and the house
fire so again it was across the street
they found allegedly a pride flag that
had apparently been burned
and then and then and then on the other
side of the street there was a house
fire
one did not cause or lead to the other
as far as anybody knows
no cause has been determined of either
fire
nobody knows if the house fire was
deliberate
and if it was we don't know why it was
started
so we know none of that whatsoever so
there are there are about four or five
leaps you'd have to make to connect the
house fire to anti-lgbt sentiment and
then there's another one or two leaps to
continue the connection all the way to
my film
yet this is the best harris can do it's
not his fault it's very difficult to
find real examples of actual anti-lgbt
violence because it hardly ever happens
that doesn't stop him from suggesting
that there's an epidemic of a type of
violence for which he could not find
even one confirmed example
that of course is the common theme with
harris and his ilk
the facts don't stop them
they simply shout their bald assertions
and then cover their ears in case anyone
shouts back
that's why harris by the way locked down
his twitter account and went to private
as soon as his article was published
that's how you know someone's really
confident in what they wrote right they
publish it and they lock everything down
and go hide
and so
hiding under his bed you know he may not
be able to hear me say it but i must say
it all the same to malcolm harris of the
new york magazine
you are today cancelled
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really that's what it
is we're forming a cult then all you do
is click the subscribe button and ring
the bell below this video to stay up to
date with all my content and if you want
even more you can watch or listen to my
show at the dailywire.com spotify or
apple podcast looking forward to
welcoming you to the sweet baby gang
you